so we have a matrix equation set up
right over here we have matrix a times
this plus matrix B times this plus
matrix C times this is equal to this 2
by 2 matrix and the way it's set up it's
a little bit of a puzzle and I'll give
you one clue as to as to what type of
matrices a B and C could be there each
either going to be an identity matrix
identity matrix or there or a zero
matrix so given that clue that each of
these are either an identity matrix or a
zero matrix can you pause this video and
essentially solve this puzzle which of
these are identity matrices and which of
these are 0 matrices assuming you've
given a go at it so let's let's go entry
by entry so if you look at this this
first entry right over here how can we
get a 2 for this this top left entry
well let's see when we multiply if if
these are idaite if any of these are
identities and essentially you just get
the value of the matrix if any of these
are 0 then essentially that product
doesn't get added that where it's so
it's one way of thinking about is that
that that matrix won't matter anymore
because going to be multiplied by 0 so
if a was a 0 matrix and B and C were
identity matrices you would add 1 plus 1
to get to see just like maybe that's the
case but it could be the other way
around it could be that a is identity
matrix B is a 0 matrix and C is an
identity matrix and you add 1 plus 1
over there to get 2 or you could say
that maybe C is the 0 matrix and B is
the identity matrix and you add 1 plus 1
here so really all this is is telling us
is two of these matrix two of two of a B
and C are going to be identity matrices
and one is going to be a zero matrix but
we don't know which one is which just
yet any of them can be the zero matrix
at least based on looking at that first
entry now let's look at I don't know
let's look at this entry right over here
how can we add up to four well let's see
3 3 if this was an identity matrix and
this was an identity matrix then you're
going to then essentially you'll just be
left with this
matrix plus this matrix this is going to
be the zero so three plus negative five
that is not equal to four so both of the
you can't have a and B B identity
matrices and C be the zero matrix so
let's think about other other
combinations here so what about B and C
being the identity identity matrices and
a being the zero matrix in that
situation so a is the zero matrix so
that's not going to matter and we're
essentially when you multiply B times
this you're just going to get this
matrix and C times this you're going to
get that matrix if B and C are identity
matrices and so you have negative 5 plus
1 would be negative 4 so that doesn't
work either so our last scenario is
going to be so we can essentially rule
out B as an identity matrix because when
we took when we when we had B be one of
the identity matrices and we picked the
other two options we still couldn't get
to 4 here so B is going to be a zero
matrix and let's see if that works out a
is identity then a would be an identity
and C would be an energy matrix as well
so let's see if that is if that actually
makes sense so if this is if this right
over here is identity matrix and that
over there is an identity matrix this
whole thing simplifies to 1 3 4 comma
negative 2 plus 1 1 3 2 and it does
indeed equal 1 plus 1 is 2 3 plus 1 is 4
4 plus 3 is 7 negative 2 plus 2 is
indeed 0